after paying more than 12 million
dollars per delegate Mike Bloomberg
drops out of the presidential race and
endorses Joe Biden meanwhile Bernie
Sanders releases a new ad starring
Barack Obama we will examine why the
establishment always wins then at a
pro-abortion rally
Rashidah Talib shrieks and Chuck Schumer
threatens two Supreme Court justices we
will analyze why pro-abortion activists
are always so crazy then Alex Trebek
gives some much-needed perspective and
finally the mailbag I'm Michael Knowles
this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
mini mic is out mini mic is out and I'm
very very sad
Bloomberg releases this statement I
always believed that defeating Donald
Trump starts with uniting behind the
candidate with the best shot to do it
after yesterday's vote it is clear that
candidate is my friend and great
American Joe Biden I've known Joe for a
very long time I know his decency his
honesty his commitment to the issues
that are so important to our country
including gun safety health care climate
change and good jobs now if Mike
Bloomberg had known that about I don't
know a few months ago he would have been
able to save 500 million dollars I
always thought Mike Bloomberg was a
smart guy you know he's had this very
successful career in finance media mogul
three-term mayor of New York but turns
out he's a complete idiot because he
blew 500 million dollars when he could
have just endorsed his decent honest
wonderful great friend Joe Biden
obviously campaign a huge waste of money
sorry to see him go because the Trump
impersonation of him was really great it
is worth pointing out though for people
who say oh my gosh Mike Bloomberg just
blew all this money what a total dolt it
is worth remembering just what 500
million dollars means to Mike Bloomberg
so 500 million to Mike Bloomberg if you
look at the median net worth of an
American who is Mike Bloomberg's age it
turns out that number is 264 thousand
eight hundred dollars okay Mike
Bloomberg is worth about sixty billion
dollars so for Mike Bloomberg to spend
five hundred million would be like the
median 77 year old American spending
twenty-two hundred bucks so it would be
like you know like a really nice
birthday present like there like a
really super nice birthday present you
know or it would be like I don't know
going on a vacation that that was Mike
Mike Bloomberg went on vacation he went
and he didn't even go like totally crazy
on vacation that's fabulous great job
Mike Bloomberg sorry to see you go
personally is on
accomplishment was winning American
Samoa politically though his
accomplishment is he may have finished
off the Democratic primary by dropping
out Mike Bloomberg has now given up all
of the establishment resistance to Joe
Biden so you've got Joe Biden now
running away with the establishment Lane
you've got Bernie Sanders in the
anti-establishment Lane and you've got
Elizabeth Warren not knowing who she is
I guess she's running anti-establishment
you know she's anti anti-establishment
in the same way that she's at Cherokee
Indian Joe Biden is doing really great
as a result of all of this Biden has now
moved up to 36% in national polls that's
according to morning consult he's now
eight points ahead nationally of where
Bernie Sanders is just 10 days ago Joe
Biden was at 19 percent in this poll so
that no it's a huge increase I mean
showing with 17 percentage points up
this helps him you know we talked a lot
about whether Joe Biden was gonna have a
viable candidacy and when he kept losing
and losing and losing he was dropping
down in all the polls he was collapsing
at the debates I said on this show Joe
Biden if he loses the electability
argument is nowhere he doesn't have
anything else people aren't gonna elect
him for his firmly held beliefs he
doesn't have any firmly held beliefs
they're not going to elect him for his
youth and vigor certainly what they're
gonna elect him for is because he has a
shot at beating Donald Trump now if he
kept losing and losing and losing
especially if you lost at Carolina that
argument goes away but the flipside is
true now as well Joe Biden blows out
South Carolina so the electability
argument looks really good and the first
rule of electoral politics is you got to
pick a winner
so Joe Biden doing very well right now
president Trump though absolutely loving
this he's loving this divide between the
establishment and the anti-establishment
we will get to Y we will get to how we
will get to a lot more craziness first I
got to thank our friends over at
ancestry DNA
I love ancestry I've been using ancestry
since before the Daily wire existed I
always loved genealogy kind of mapping
out
my family now ancestry DNA can reveal
ethnic origins and provide historical
details that bring unique family stories
to life so they're they're not just
gonna go look and say okay you're 25%
Italian and 25% it's not like that it I
mean it'll tell you that too but also
with ancestry DNA you can trace the
paths of your recent ancestors you can
learn how and why your family moved from
place to place around the world that is
a unique service offered from from
ancestry DNA it's easy to start making
discoveries just go grab an ancestry DNA
kit and start a free trial to amplify
your discoveries offend out really cool
stuff about my guys I mean for the
Mayflower ancestors found out one of
them is a he was like a good guy he was
a pilgrim and then the other three were
complete degenerate then on the Italian
side I got to trace them moving out of
Sicily just a fabulous service start
exploring your family story today head
to my URL at ancestry.com slash Knowles
canna wles that is ancestry.com slash
Knowles canna wles
to get your ancestry DNA kit and start
your free trial ancestry.com slash
Knowles Trump is just loving all of this
so so president Trump just tweeted out
amid all of the chaos and in the
Democratic primary he goes quote the
Democrat establishment came together and
crushed Bernie Sanders again even the
fact that Elizabeth Warren stayed in the
race was devastating to Bernie and
allowed sleepy Joe to unthinkably win
Massachusetts it was a perfect storm
with many good states remaining for Joe
he's not done so selfish for Elizabeth
Warren to stay in the race she has zero
chance of even coming close to winning
but hurts Bernie badly so much for their
wonderful liberal friendship will he
ever speak to her again
she cost in Massachusetts and came in
third he shouldn't write so he's rubbing
salt in the wound all he wants to do is
irritate this Democratic primary right
the best thing he can hope for even more
important than who wins is just to cause
bitter bitter rancor within the party so
that the Bernie bros don't vote for
Biden or if
Burnie somehow wins it that the
establishment won't vote for Bernie
they'll be so demoralized now bernie is
not taking this lying down
a week ago Bernie Sanders was was
running away with the Democratic
nomination he was doing just great and
now everyone's come together they're
gonna crush him well he's not ready for
that yet so he just released an ad
really takes some cojones to release
this ad he is putting forward the next
leg of his campaign by showing how much
Barack Obama loves him
Bernie is somebody who has the virtue of
saying exactly what he believes great
authenticity great passion and is
fearless Bernie served on the Veterans
Committee and got bills done
I think people are ready for a call to
action they want honest leadership who
cares about them
who's gonna fight for them and they and
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm Bernie Sanders this message yeah
take that Joe yeah you like that you
like how that feels it's so really
brilliant campaign ad this is really
smart he's doing it for two reasons one
is to needle Joe Biden buy Biden's
former boss saying all these wonderful
things about Bernie Sanders and yet that
same guy Barack Obama has not come out
and endorsed Joe Biden yet that's pretty
embarrassing that's humiliating the
second reason is Bernie Sanders is now
probably too little too late
trying to make a play to win over some
establishment support so in that ad it
would seem like Barack Obama is
endorsing Bernie Sanders right they're
walking together in the White House he's
saying all these great things say I'm
feeling the Bern you got a fighter in
Bernie Sanders but he has an endorsed
Bernie Sanders seems worse Bernie for
Senate I guess but he didn't endorse
Bernie Sanders for president he hasn't
made an endorsement yet so it's a little
deceptive I mean it's a little
duplicitous for him to do that really
brilliant ad though because other than
just really getting under Joe Biden's
skin Bernie realizes that he made a
mistake
Bernie's mistake was he's always been
the outsider anti-establishment
candidate just railing against the man
but matter if he accomplishes anything
he doesn't have to it actually hurts him
if he accomplishes something because
then he's not an outsider then he's part
of the swamp then he's wheeling and
dealing and compromising so he's always
running this way since he was a getting
kicked off a commune right he's always
been that radical when Bernie became the
front-runner in the Democratic Party
there was certainly a path for him that
expose there still is the path for him
to become the president but he's got to
start acting like a nominee he can't
just act like the angry old codger who's
you know yelling at kids to get off his
lawn that's fine in a primary to an
extent but you you need to act like the
candidate you have to act like the
front-runner at a certain point you know
president Trump descending the stairs at
Trump Tower was announcing his campaign
all he's doing is throwing bombs all he
is is the outsider but eventually he
takes on the leadership of that primary
he starts acting like the front-runner
Berni failed to do that I think his
advisors certainly at least realize this
was a mistake so he's gonna start making
that play now and a Bernie Sanders who
can appeal to the establishment sounds
like a contradiction in terms but that
could be a really potent force if we can
pull it off President Trump for his part
of course is Fanning the flames so you
know Trump's whole strategy is say nice
things about Bernie say mean things
about Joe Biden and Mike Bloomberg now
what President Trump is trying to avoid
is a unified Democratic Party so if they
get to the convention let's say Joe
Biden gets it and Bernie Sanders says
okay Joe you you know you won fair and
square Joe so I endorsed you or
something to that effect that would be
very bad for for president Trump so he's
out there and he's gonna rallies and he
much like Bernie Sanders is needling Joe
Biden Trump is now needling Bernie
Sanders and implying that if Bernie were
to get on board with Joe Biden he would
be a sellout he would be a fraud he
would be pathetic you convinced now it's
Biden's to lose I think so I just don't
know you know how he gets there I don't
know how he gets across the line maybe
he will maybe it's suno's he was always
very gaffe prone II was always he was
always in trouble in that way but never
like this you know this is going what's
going on now is crazy but I think
they'll do anything to assume power and
if they think he can do better than
Bernie and I guess they have less
control over Bernie you know Bernie is
more for himself but I was surprised
when Bernie got beaten up last time that
he went out and endorsed Hillary and
went around and did like a good puppy
like he's supposed to do I was a little
surprised at that and even this time as
he was saying about how wonderful you
know Joe Biden is a wonderful guy
wonderful man and um you know I'm a
little bit surprised by it's almost like
he's I don't know if he's admitting
defeat he might be but I watched him
yesterday saying or just a little while
ago saying very good things about sleepy
Joe Biden and I was a little bit
surprised and I was just a little
surprised that Bernie's acting like a
little puppy you know like a good little
puppy
yeah like a punk like oh oh he's so this
is this is when Trump is at his absolute
best this this man is the leader of the
free world and he's calling in to Sean
Hannity's cable show and and playing
kind of the role of pundit provocateur
comedian just pushing him right he
starts out with the compliment started
saying yeah you know I was really
respected Bernie Bernie is a little more
for himself he can't be controlled yeah
you know he's like a real man he's a
real guy except he's acting like a total
loser
oh yeah he's acting like just a wimp you
know he's just letting himself get
pushed around by the Democrats and I
hope you doesn't do that again it's so
sad it's so pathetic
that's a pretty good strategy what he's
doing is trying not only to incite
Bernie here he's trying to back Bernie
into a corner I don't think that Bernie
is gonna be completely emotionally
manipulative I think what President
Trump is doing maybe there's a little
bit of that but what he's really trying
to do is politically position at such
that Bernie Sanders can't face his
supporters and say okay it was a good
fight but I support Joe because his
supporters will eat him alive he wants
to make it such that or Trump wants to
make it such that Bernie has no other
way to turn but to fight this thing out
until the end and so far I think that's
going pretty well the fact that that
Bernie would release that ad insinuating
that Obama endorsed him that's a pretty
strong sign that Bernie Sanders is not
going anywhere anytime soon and that
just sounds great to me turning away
from 20/20 down to the Supreme Court
there's a big Supreme Court case coming
down the pike that it will really
challenge the abortion regime in America
this case is about the Louisiana
abortion law that there are so many
abortion laws that came out last year
right there was Louisiana there was
Missouri there was Georgia there all all
these different laws so it's sometimes
hard to keep keep track of them but the
issue at play here in the Louisiana
abortion law is that abortionists
according to the law need to have
admitting
privileges at a nearby hospital that's
it that's the issue that's going to the
Supreme Court it's not that they're
gonna outlaw abortion everywhere it's
not it's not that it's a pretty pretty
simple totally reasonable idea that if
you're an abortionist in Louisiana you
need to have admitting privileges at a
hospital you know you need to have high
medical standards we don't want women
being hurt in this we don't want the
procedure to happen at all we don't want
any abortion but we also don't want
women to die or be hurt as a result of
this we want actual doctors doing it not
just cheap killers so there's a rally
yesterday outside the Supreme Court we
saw one of the craziest displays from
the activist level all the way up to the
Minority Leader of the US Senate and it
shows you something about this issue we
will get to that in a second first I got
to thank our friends over at legacy box
legacy box is so great it is a way for
you to easily and affordably digitally
preserve your past this has happened
especially for me with family members
who have died you know I've got these
photos that I really want to save but
the photos start to fade film you know
VHS definitely starts to fade so I
thought I don't know they're just gonna
go away I'm not gonna have any memories
you just send them or you know a fire
happens or you move or you'll lose them
whatever you send in these photos to
legacy box they digitized everything for
you they share it with you you get a
thumb drive DVD you get it on the cloud
it's ready to watch share and enjoy such
a great idea invest in your past invest
in your memories and in your family get
started preserving your past today go to
legacy box.com slash knowles kano wles
to get an incredible 40% off your first
order so get all get all those orders in
there 40% off your first order buy today
take advantage of this exclusive order
send it in when you're ready legacy
box.com slash Knowles save 40% while
supplies last so we saw this
pro-abortion rally to protest the case
that's coming up yesterday was outside
the Supreme Court this woman hears an
abortion activist this woman listen to
the tone of her voice listen even beyond
the arc
humans she's making listen simply to how
she sounds
tells you a lot about the abortion issue
and a special shout-out to where my
people who had abortions so as I said I
had abortions when I was 19 it was
honestly one of the best decisions of my
life I was simply not ready to become a
parent and that's really all you need to
know hey lady
who you trying to convince who are you
trying to convince I mean you just see
it is she's so strained she's so pushing
this narrative out there I'm so happy
that I killed my child I've what a great
decision I made I definitely don't
regret that and it hasn't really damaged
my life I mean anybody with eyes and
ears can see that this is a tortured
woman you hear it in her voice that
shrieking the screaming the tension in
what she's saying of course I mean
people look people make mistakes all the
time okay if you make a mistake even if
it's a mistake that bad
you can regret it ask forgiveness move
on but but these people can't they can't
get over the pride and the horror that
they may have committed such an
egregious act and it's not just one or
two random activists I mean political
activists generally they can be sort of
eccentric people right but it's it's the
same sort of tone of voice it's the same
kind of shrill angry tense uncredible
incredible tone that you see with
congressmen and with senators when they
do it
Rashidah to leave but one of the members
of the squad goes out there the exact
same rally same tone of voice same
ridiculous arguments
that's with our bodies how we talk how
we love what we stand for I mean this
type of police scene of our bodies is so
interconnected to all the social justice
movements all around the country
I represent the third poorest
congressional district in the country
this issue is an economic justice issue
this issue is a racial justice issue and
let me tell you this obsession with our
bodies
you know I in the legislature the
Michigan Legislature for six years used
to say people to people yo-yo you know
why you're so freakin obsessed with what
I decide to do with my body
maybe you shouldn't even want to have
sex with me hold on pause it right there
I just need to correct the record before
Rasheeda Talib continues that is not
something I have ever wanted to do not
that is of all the things that one could
imagine doing with Rasheeda Talib that
is not one of them so please do not
accuse me of ever to do that that the
things of the list of things I want to
do just in general in the world that is
very very far down near at the bottom
she goes on we won't stand by for you to
commercialize for you to profit for you
to do all the things you do to what to
make us less than in this country
because that's what it does
and there it is that's her whole
argument right she's making all of these
really stupid slogan e arguments they're
like bumper stickers they don't mean
anything when she says we want to
control our bodies no they don't I mean
anybody who is even somewhat honest
about the abortion issue would say it's
not about your body that people are
concerned it's the child's body so it
isn't that they say it's about making us
less than no it's about we don't think
you should kill babies that's what it's
about if you can try to argue that or
you say it's we have to be able to kill
babies for equality but at least be
honest about the issue so she puts out
these slogans and then she finally gets
to her real argument which is there's
more of us than there are of them that's
not a moral argument there's more of us
than them it's not an argument from
justice or it's not not ethical at all
you're just saying that you're a mob and
you're gonna force your will on other
people justice be damned unborn baby be
damned who cares you're just gonna do it
this was actually the subject of my talk
last night at UC Santa Santa Cruz I was
giving a talk on when democracy goes
wrong when democracy goes wrong is when
people start making arguments like this
which is there's more of us than them
that's that's not coherent I mean duh
yeah I guess any mob any lynch mob in
the world can go and affect their will
on somebody that doesn't make it right
that's you've got to argue beyond that
but Rashidah to leave can't why I don't
know anything about Rashidah to leaves
past I just know about her political
ideology and I know that she is trying
to convince a lot of people maybe
herself of this argument that is
untenable it's indefensible it's why she
gets shrill it's why she shrieks it's
why she makes these slogan arguments
that fall flat and it's eventually why
she says I want it I mean that's what
that means right there's more of us than
them is I want it I'm gonna do it me me
me me and not very convincing to the
rest of us then it wasn't just rashida
to leave it went even higher than that
to the Senate Minority Leader
Schumer who took this argument rather
than talking about his body or having
sex with him thank goodness he talked
about how he was going to threaten two
justices on the Supreme Court if they
permitted this restriction on abortion
if they permitted the Louisiana law
which forces abortionists to at least
have admitting privileges at hospitals
here's the crazed Schumer I want to tell
you Gorsuch I want to tell you Kavanagh
you have released the whirlwind and you
will pay the price you won't know what
hit you you will pay the price you won't
know what hit you so that's not just
criticism of Supreme Court justices
right now the Democrats are trying to
spin this and say oh he was just
criticizing the Supreme Court that's
fine that's perfectly within bounds he
wasn't doing that he said you won't know
what hit you
we're coming after you what does that
mean Supreme Court justices have life
tenure so it's not like they're gonna
say we're gonna get you out in the next
election you won't know what hit you
especially at this very intense shrieky
rally just so you can hear it in his
voice - there's something about the
abortion issue that makes people lose
their minds and sound like demons they
said just listen to the voices like ah
or as like I was waiting for them to
start speaking Latin backwards it's so
ugly it's so it's different than any
other issue and I I think part of that
is because they know that there's no
coherent argument so all they can do is
enforce their will
it's not about reason it's about will
and a part of it I think is because it's
it's simply evil abortion is evil and
evil warps people's minds for his part
the Chief Justice of the Supreme Court
John Roberts issued a rare statement in
response to Schumer's threat he said
quote this was obviously a written
statement this morning Senator Schumer
spoke at a rally in front of the Supreme
Court while a case was being argued
inside Senator Schumer referred to two
members of the Supreme Court by name and
said he wanted to tell them that quote
you have released the whirlwind and you
will pay the price you will not know
what hit you if you go forward with
these awful decisions Justices know that
criticism comes with the territory but
threatening statements of this sort from
the highest levels of government are not
only inappropriate they are dangerous
all members of the court will continue
to do their jobs without fear or favor
from whatever quarter great statement
from the Chief Justice who always tries
to remain the most neutral guy in the
room sometimes to ill effect because he
won't stand up for things that are right
but this was this was true this is
absolutely beyond the bounds the next
time they tell you that Donald Trump is
destroying norms and decency in this
country remember Chuck Schumer Chuck
Schumer threatening two members of the
Supreme Court the next time they tell
you about all that oh how terrible the
the tweets the mean tweets Trump is so
outrageous remember this line this is
the Chuck Schumer line maybe the most
egregious statement from a senior
government official that I've seen in my
lifetime I don't think I've seen
anything close to this shows you were
kind of careening toward rancor and
division and it's it's being led by the
left it's not it's not being led by the
right
Alex Trebek will show us a little
perspective on this
Alex Trebek the longtime host of
Jeopardy he was diagnosed a year ago
with pancreatic cancer Stage four
pancreatic cancer where that you know
it's not a good look when you get Stage
four pancreatic cancer usually you're
gone within a few months a year later
Alex Trebek is still alive and he gave
his viewers an update about this I think
we could all learn something from
Trebek's update and attitude hi everyone
if you've got a minute I'd like to bring
you up to date on my health situation
the one-year survival rate for Stage
four pancreatic cancer patients is 18%
I'm very happy to report I have just
reached that marker now I'd be lying if
I said the journey had been an easy one
there were some good days but a lot of
not so good days I joked with friends
that the cancer won't kill me the chemo
treatments will there were moments of
great pain days when certain bodily
functions no longer functioned and
sudden massive attacks of great
depression that made me wonder if it
really was worth fighting on but I
brushed that aside quickly because that
would have been a massive betrayal a
betrayal of my wife and soul mate Jean
who has given her all to help me survive
it would have been a betrayal of other
cancer patients who have looked to me as
an inspiration and a cheerleader of
sorts of the value of living and hope
and it would certainly have been a
betrayal of my faith in God and the
millions of prayers that have been said
on my behalf what a statement what a guy
what an outlook he's got pretty much the
worst health condition you can possibly
have he somehow miraculously survives a
whole year already and he says I'm just
so grateful I feel a sense of duty I
would never give up hope because I don't
want to betray you and don't betray my
family and most important I don't want
to betray my god whoa what an attitude
this guy's going through some serious
problems compare that to I was at UC
Santa Cruz last night I'm still in Santa
Cruz the grad students are on strike
because I think they're making something
like $35 an hour and they want to make
$50 an hour so they're on strike and
they're not doing their jobs and they
won't grade the papers and they're
furious they're angry they're committing
acts of violence they're committing like
felonies actually and their protest of
the administration two attitudes one of
humility gratitude Duty one of
entitlement anger resentment selfishness
Hillary Clinton before we get to mailbag
I've got a Hillary Clinton might be the
political embodiment of all this Hillary
Clinton just did an interview on ABC
News and she was asked in this interview
how it felt to really really have won
the presidential election but
to just not be the president for
whatever reason back would it have been
more easy to handle losing outright than
to of really one but still lost that was
really tough it was not only winning by
three million votes and and having all
the weird things happen at the end that
interfered with my votes really really
she won you know that we all know that
but it's just because of some like
little random technicality like the
Constitution or the people who voted or
something she's not the president that
attitude of just resentment entitlement
delusion it just makes you look
ridiculous you look at her we've just
all laugh at Hillary Clinton right we
laugh at the ABC journalist journalist
too we laugh at the grad students at
UCSC they just look so small so petty
and then you look at it I like Alex
Trebek and you say wow what a man what a
guy what an attitude be like Alex Trebek
we have got to get to the mailbag we
will get to that in a second first I've
got to say goodbye to Facebook and
YouTube and before we do that I've got
to encourage you to go get drew
Clayton's new book the nightmare feast
this is the second book in the another
Kingdom trilogy I voiced the entire
another Kingdom trilogy both in the
podcast and in the audiobooks we're
about to go into the studio to do the
second books audiobook next week just a
tremendous trilogy and it's one of these
weird trilogies where it gets better
with each book so the first one is very
good at jump to the top of the charts on
Apple podcasts then the second one is
better and the third one is best of all
and you got to read the second to read
the third I go get it right now you get
it anywhere that excellent books are
sold it's about an a Dalek Hollywood
screenwriter who can't catch a break
walks through a door into another
Kingdom where there are ochres and and
monsters and damsels who are dying with
daggers in their chest that the book is
really really profound it's got an
incredible cultural and spiritual
message so go go check it out and also
by the way Super Tuesday is over but
according to Joe Biden super Thursday is
on the way
and right now we are offering 25 percent
off all daily Huayra membership plans
when you use coupon code
never socialist this is my favorite
coupon code we've had so far it's
important you remember that code just
like it's important that Joe Biden
remembers the Declaration of
Independence you know go go to daily
wire.com slash subscribe and get the the
thing you know you know the thing you
get everything you get all the shows you
get to ask questions in the mailbag you
get if you're at the all-access tear you
get to ask questions in QA s you get the
leftist terior Stumbler and you get the
daily wire app you get so much 25% off
daily wire memberships use the coupon
code never socialist for Super Thursday
as that what Joe Biden is calling it
super Thursday daily wire.com slash
subscribe we'll be right back
let's get into the mailbag from confused
girlfriend dear Michael Knowles I
greatly enjoy your show and would like
your opinion on dating I met a guy while
working on my master's degree and have
been dating him for the past four months
he does all the right dating things like
paying for dinner opening his truck door
and he even drives me home after classes
every day since we met at a university I
thought he would be a little
left-leaning
I did not expect him to be a
self-proclaimed Bernie bro so my
question is do you think a hardcore
conservative and a Bernie bro have a
future Thanks it depends it depends how
much of a Bernie bro he is I think some
people say their Bernie bros just for
the meme just because it's kind of
contrarian and you know they're young
and young people tend to be liberal and
they then they become more conservative
the reason I'm not saying just dump him
outright is because he pays for dinner
Bernie Sanders wouldn't pay for dinner
Bernie Sanders would reach into your
pocket while you were out at patterning
your nose
he holds the truck door open and I know
that Bernie Sanders would hold that
truck door open
we need equality now men don't hold
doors open for women so he sounds like
more than anything he's a confused young
man and what you should do is push him
on this get you know push him a little
bit on the political questions that make
him a Bernie bro and then the cultural
questions and ultimately the religious
questions because don't forget Marxism
posits a kind of worldview that takes
the place of religion right it's the it
was referred to as the God that failed
by Ronald Reagan and many others so I
would push him on that a little bit see
where he falls a lot of people are
liberal when they're young even I went
through a liberal phase and I was pretty
much born into this world smoking a
cigar with parted hair so you know see
where it stands he pushed him a little
bit maybe get to some deeper issues to
you know cultural issues values religion
that kind of thing and maybe I'd give
him a little bit of chance the minute he
stops paying for dinner though he's gone
from Reagan you answered a question once
before about yoga and
practicing yoga as a Christian with the
breathing and chants etc I was wondering
about your opinion on astrology the
stars are real
so are the noticed patterns type so are
the noticed patterns a type of religion
therefore should it not be accepted at
all by Christians I personally find it
interesting but give little credit to it
thanks well the Bible is pretty clear
you should not consult astrologers and
the reason for this when you talk to
atheists about it they say they say oh
that's so ridiculous it's so bogus
that's so crazy
you know but Christians don't
necessarily say that astrology and all
these kind of weird little esoteric
religions are crazy we just say they're
bad you shouldn't do it you've got your
own religion right love the Lord your
God or just you got one guy that's it
okay and then there are these other
pseudo religions like astrology for
instance or gender theory is another
kind of religious worldview which says
that my body has nothing to do with Who
I am but I'm just secretly something
else and I've got to change my body to
get more in line with whatever I
metaphysically am all these different
religions that you've got to reject
because your God is a jealous God
same thing with yoga you know you looked
it does it matter if you go out and
stretch no but the thing about yoga is
that it is a liturgical practice I mean
people treat yoga like Church you do
chanting it's got this very spiritual
element to it and it's not the spiritual
world that you believe in apparently so
you got to kind of pick and choose if
you want to go stretch go find go
stretch you want to go do Pilates that
sounds good but you don't need to do
this liturgical thing and when it comes
to astrology I would not consult
astrologists is so funny I live in LA
you know so everyone's an atheist but
they all are totally into their zodiac
signs and they all completely believe it
I think wait a second guys hold on it's
you you can't believe in the dominant
religion that has you know has the most
explanatory power that has shaped our
entire civilization but you believe that
some little blurb in the newspaper is
going to tell you your future that's a
little weird it's because it's because I
think atheists believe religious people
Christians especially are superstitious
when
ironically really religious people are
the least superstitious people on earth
and actually it's the people who think
that they're not religious they tend to
fall into the most superstition but in
short I would stay away from astrology
from Nick Michael where did this huge
push for saving the cows come from like
why not focus on saving whales deer or
Amy Schumer curious to know your
thoughts Thanks the reason that the left
now is focusing on saving the cows and
you can't milk the cows more than any
other issue is because the left wants it
to hurt the left wants to feel a little
pain a little penance a little
discipline and when it comes to cows
people like hamburgers when it comes to
dairy they like cheese they like milk
and they want to feel it this comes from
the same kind of religious impulse right
we all know that we're broken people we
all know that we're fallen and so we
acknowledge that we acknowledge our sins
we confess our sins we do penance we
atone for the left
they don't have an outlet for that or
they don't think they have an outlet for
that so they don't admit that human
beings are irreparably flawed right they
believe in the perfect ability of human
nature they believe in Utopia so often
they believe that they're good people
they celebrate pride right the sin that
actually causes mankind to fall so they
believe in all this stuff but they know
that they're kind of rotten because look
if you look in a mirror long enough you
can figure it out that you're a kind of
rotten person and so they feel that they
need to atone for their sin of whatever
causing suffering to the cows or
something and whereas there were not
many simpler ways to help the
environment help animals rather than
just giving up milk I mean ironically if
you don't milk a cow the cow is in pain
but people like milk people like cheese
so they want to feel it themselves they
want to say like you in the Catholic
Church you say Mia culpa maiya culpa mea
Maxima culpa my fault my fault through
my most grievous fault and that's what
they're doing by not drinking milk so
Joaquin Phoenix is feeling - from Andrew
do you support term limits for members
of Congress and why Thanks no I don't
and I don't because I think that term
for members of Congress would not reduce
the power of the federal government it
would not reduce the interference that
the federal government has in my life it
would simply make the federal government
less accountable why would the federal
government be less accountable because
the actual members of Congress would
have even less power than they do now
and instead the people running Congress
would be the staff and would be the
lobbyists to an extent this is already
true you know the people who are in
Congress the longest sometimes are the
staff and the staff don't get elected
especially if you're on a committee or
something like that you're just there
forever the lobbyists are there forever
the the elected officials come and go
but the lobbyists remain the swamp
remains the bureaucracy remains the
biggest threat to our Liberty from the
federal government is this entrenched
bureaucracy at the executive agencies in
particular so I think would be a huge
mistake to set up term limits in
Congress that would empower the
congressional bureaucracy even more we
have term limits in this country they
were set up by the Constitution they're
called elections from Kyle I Michael one
topic I have not heard discussed often
is whether child support payments should
be required during pregnancy if a man
and woman are divorced or separated you
to father be legally required to
financially support a pregnant mother
this would mean that man could be held
responsible for medical expenses as well
as increased financial assistance toward
the end of pregnancy when the woman is
no longer able to work do you think
conservatives would get behind this
policy this is a great idea there's a
little bit of a issue with it which is
that if the man and woman are you know
the woman becomes pregnant and then they
divorce right after she becomes pregnant
that's a pretty bad marriage I mean
you're in a pretty rotten place if
you're gonna get divorced right after
pregnancy let's say that they're not
married you know just one nightstand and
the woman becomes pregnant they should
get married the two people should then
get married that the answer to that is
not that he should pay a little bit more
money in child support the answer to
that is they should get married if a guy
husband impregnates his wife and then
they want to get
right afterward the answer to that is
they should not get divorced in
virtually all cases some cases you do
need a separation you know if you're in
abuse or something like that but
virtually all cases all cases that we
really talk about that I think are being
referred to here just stay married okay
that's that would be the preference we
need to encourage marriage we need to
change laws governing the ease of
divorce laws governing family courts for
instance barring all of that I think in
principle of course it's a great idea
you know the woman is gonna have a lot
of expenses when she gets pregnant and
so the man who impregnated her the
father of the baby should certainly pay
for that and the other reason this is a
great idea is the left could could
accept this argument because it is
feminist I guess you know it helps the
woman but the right would love this
argument because of course then everyone
would have to acknowledge that the baby
is a baby even before he's born from
Ryan hi Michael
last night on backstage you guys were
debating about how conservatism should
be defined it was suggested that
conservatism should be defined by
specific principles rather than general
inclinations if I have properly listed
listen to what you've said this is
something that you disagree with could
you explain why it is best for
conservatism to be an inclination rather
than a set of principles thank you for a
great show yes this is a big
disagreement between the libertarian
right wing and the conservative right
wing or the traditionalist right wing
the libertarianism is an ideology okay
so you can list it on a sheet of paper
it's a manifesto it's got these it's
governed by abstract principles it's a
rationalist modernist ideology
conservatism is not or at least it's not
supposed to be a conservatism modern
conservatism comes to us from Edmund
Burke who is great irish fallar Irish
Anglo philosopher and you see this
history throughout America - Edmund
Burke was a big supporter of the
American Revolution a Russell Kirk wrote
a great book about this called the
American mind where he kind of traces
the evolution of conservative thought
another great book on
is Michael okay Michael Oakshott is a
great author on this the book is
rationalism in politics
the trouble with ideology that Michael
Oakshott describes in this essay is that
ideology is just so narrow it's so wrong
you're just sort of formalizing and
abstracting and abridging just the kind
of very narrowly rational truths that
you can deduce from the whole wide world
from all of our tradition that's not
very conservative that is ultimately a
modernist rationalist idea it's not
terribly different in its premises from
leftism whereas the conservative knows
the world is a lot bigger than that okay
Edmund Burke's great insight is that
we're not just about these rationalist
values that we're gonna abstract and we
think they're floating in the air that
actually the conservative worldview
relies a lot on Providence a lot on
tradition the received wisdom of the
ages humility before the tradition
before our ancestors we've inherited
something here okay we have a cultural
inheritance we have a family we're not
born into the world
it's just abstract atoms floating around
but we're actually conserving something
and I think that the concern that
version of conservatism but it's an
inclination rather than just some
ideology is much more coherent much more
sustainable the early conservative loss
for Edmund Burke was an aesthetic
philosopher he was a philosopher about
beauty you know conservatives unlike
shrieking Rasheeda Talib we enjoy things
conservatives tend to be a little hat
yeah a little more at peace in the world
right of course we are
we want to conserve what we've got
whereas the left they don't like what
they see they're always kind of angry
they're always sort of negative right
they just want to move past this
everything bothers them and and I fear
when right-wingers adopt this
ideological view that conservatism
capital see with a trademark over the EM
is just five bullet points on a
manifesto I find they kind of take on
the same aspect as the left the same
premises as the left and that's a losing
even if it were preferable it's a losing
bet because the left is always going to
be better at being leftist than we are
all right that's our show
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Nolt sure I'm gonna be filling in on the
bench Shapiro radio show today so tune
in there otherwise see on Monday
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Ben Davies and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy borin
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director pavel
whanau ski editor and associate producer
danny D'Amico audio mixer robin
Fenderson hair and makeup nikka geneva
production assistant ryan love the
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
you know the Matt Walsh show it's not
just another show about about politics I
think there are enough of those already
out there we talk about culture because
culture drives politics and it drives
everything else so my main focus is our
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about I
hope you'll give it a listen
you